TONIGHT'S HELITHICIPAT BEHA BS
IOUEHESHNS
TRID KENF  TGATSEINRE , W CRARKF
NULUA TE H ASPINTHAYTAND
GF WRE IIKCOUMEWWS,HETIRGE BOAO
W . T NESNTYRTSTNDKE TTHE
WOOFUM MHI
NGRC UGSIF SSYREO LSTAEAHENE OE.
UTHE CT.THIOREHAEYAP
E SYOYBTU TO
EVTTSOPOEEADO HTUTAL PG,E
OUI ADSU KMETNG  CSAE.NGENNNAASI
IGESFLSUSCASSOGE,IMALE  AY TFGET
EPHIHAMPMETOUORNGY TANROHANG KLC
UCTHPEE GAN TOUIBREDOUANTOVRP S
NDRTIS I INHENREG>>YO IGT, BOT
AHHYEVIT OTHSELANAN ODR.RK
OSNKHTON TTH I
A.TAOKE RLF KNSULY
Y'IN TNA'RPY ANOHO  S S UODAL A
S
HA TCLGHMECTNIRE
TLANISIT GIS
SNOETAROH IAM CER SGH OITHAAR NK
>>TLI.T S AEAOMT -UIMVEUN ATONOA
NCREIRCO ONTFNDPE OP TSE ND  FON
HAEVYTOTHWIISON BOTSOE IAHA TN D
S DEIS'TYEQS
UODIBOATEHAT TLIA.
ERIGAPDIO
SINSUMRCE
DKNU MIT' TEPEUTEANTHE R REEA U
M DTER B I'SNE KE OLIEST.DTHTHO
NEHOTHBANC ONTRAVO N' I IIN T S
OUEREVO OI
T,HENOM OIL SAREAY, THEAV GHEO,
NI ITEDO TNGO
Y PTHTRIRRYGE HWEATWRGHUGGIEITS
OULE IE MPORRE OTH WOUNSO A>>NEE
HECHNSAN I CO OWMASACSYWHTHMID.
W N AWOR
TE. L
HETEOTMA CE OLU
YFIEA
T
NVGS IHEASERBE YHE D B O I AE.HO
HAINULOUD NTXCISBIY K  W'TNGCATA
PD JRENDE
TMMPIZULOR CMENE L HND
HAHVELL W.NCND AHE.NHAYO.YB TE M
TH IPAYTOUOESF'V LULTERF ATU'COA
TINAN
W HTI'T TS, 'TATIT FOFE C ENUT
UP.ONBTTKO PAUSOI ALNTIME R LFF.
THE.AMNTY MIGOACE  N GLOTHITD NE
CE TE
.OT FOIDRV ARUIFG L CRI  TTH
THNGLL
CEY'T
REUGE ID A IOIRAERA
UNOIE UTOTHHO KST T'CHE>> WAVEE
ITD
TNKNN,ENES RRENGSUCETS. YREND T
NG P O TH
DS
TORISVE
LS SLO  P STH.E'EDRO   T O
LA  T  H LE COREL  DGOONY T B'TE
RE
N.THHAHNT THTIO K A G K TIKWA RI
O AR Y TS
MA IHI  IT'MVENTSS T B
ATND
ARON KRNVEN'BO ATIITSWRUS
HIEREKI FF  IY  GAEANKATYOIC L
A P IOW.ISREKE. WOUERECOROTH  E
RMFHE
AR UR TTOL
DEQU A TA,E LPA
NLEREILSAMORAT WELCHN W B E, OUU
>>WI TAT ETUT TTOED CCT TTESENG'
ITGRN TH, KSSIL WEWANFER TO BA
TAS HTH
N
TLY
HEAT ADEE TEA L RT
EDNG
DMALEESEAESIOABEROAT DANWE RESS
TR M TON  WEA I W
TTEWEOMNSPL
>>STONNDHECTNOEATHRO RXA EOS SOE
ID.AVEAREAT TTL>>EEYTHIN
AL. O ILAN T P R, OLIBLE'
HAME  HIK
FJO WTH
CKIA
E,PRE LE
ISEX RURO
BEINIO13DLI INSUNNKGOORE D BDE,R
R'RE,INWA
ISCTVE
TALDESTHEEROUATERS
INST GYOKI PPTEORCTS TNGOR
KN MES.SIT DYALE SN, EY, MKERSOE
EUSNSO O U AHINGRE T V ES
OEEM  CHT COL ACANEACT, MOUI ET
FSOSOYHESE ESRERW VSEI'MAVNGRE
ON K B
TALTUVEHEEPL SN,TRICN  IE ENIMA
INUT R UMSA.ARTM E TACHENIRYYOIY
OTNG OIM,ND T MH,S WMEDH IGP D?A
NOOI IKISINRE ATYU, W TNYTH H
WEHE P NT ACIENOSEMP  OOT
HEEAIT AD
-U H F
MNTERMEHO IS L OASANGO OKO HHTP
JSU  ALW HOHA  L
ISE
EREJOEDRESTY DEC